do you think wives typically go to
Carnival it depends on what you're doing
about Carnival I guess really
everything's a bit subjective when it
comes to carnivorous part of people's
culture right I know it's associated
with like things like what's it
associated with I'm new to it really
yeah let me know well I think again as I
associate with whining and like yeah
promiscuous dancing but support the
culture so if you had a girlfriend would
you be okay with her going to Carnival
by yourself I don't know it depends on
the goal a girl that wants to go to
Carnival I don't know I haven't been in
that situation I'll figure out when I
get there but genuinely I don't think
it's a problem she's like a Caribbean
that's like obviously what she's about